on va revenir bien évidemment sur sur
ces quelques mots prononcés par donald
trump
céline le temps plein on avait un donald
trump confiant donc au départ il a
énuméré un tous les états où il a
remporté selon lui donc voilà le plus
grand nombre d'électeurs
on parle du texas de la floride deux des
plus gros état en termes de nombre de
grands électeurs l'ohio la géorgie et il
a même parlé de la pennsylvanie il
n'aurait remporté en parlant de
l'arizona par exemple il a dit que
finalement c'était un homme même s'il le
remporterait pas ce n'est pas très grave
aujourd'hui donald trump revendique sa
victoire oui très clairement il a
commencé par dire que certains étaient
en train de lui voter que les démocrates
étaient encore en train de lui voler
l'élection
il a recommencé sur le thème de la
fraude électorale et il a énuméré petit
à petit les états dans lesquels ils se
pensent vainqueur mais beaucoup de ces
états n'ont pas encore enfin le
dépouillement n'est pas encore terminée
dans de nombreux de dans de nombreux
états qui laquelle la cité pour la
floride l'ohio et le texas je pense que
il est clair qu'il a remportés ces états
là mais pour la géorgie la caroline du
nord la pennsylvanie ce n'est pas aussi
clair et aussi tranché qu'il semble le
dire puisque comme vous l'avez dit tout
à l'heure en pennsylvanie notamment les
votes par correspondance pourrait être
dépouillé jusqu'à vendredi
l'état a été autorisé à recompter s'est
fait raconter ces votes ces voies
jusqu'à la fin de la semaine lui
revendique une avance de 690 mille voix
il n'est pas pour l'instant en mesure de
le déclarer puisque beaucoup de voix ne
sont pas encore beaucoup de votes ne
sont pas encore dépouillés il a
également revendiqué la victoire dans le
michigan qui est en été acquis pour
l'instant je pense n'a pas clairement
basculé dans son camp
il a prévenu qu'une bataille juridique
allait s'engager il a accusé d'ailleurs
les démocrates de vouloir l' engagées
contre lui et de vouloir mobiliser la
cour suprême contre contre lui donc en
même temps il déclare que il s'agit
d'une fraude électorale et déclare jeu
ce sont les démocrates qui engageront
une bataille juridique alors que c'est
lui qui revendique les la victoire donc
c'est tout à fait caractéristique de
donald trump
justement avant même de prendre la
parole aujourd'hui on sait que donald
trump avait déjà fait savoir pendant sa
campagne électorale qu'il allait
contester le scrutin s'il ne sortait pas
vainqueur alors c'est un fait rare bien
évidemment dans l'histoire des états
unis mais ce n'est pas inédit on a eu le
même cas de figure lors de l'élection
entre george bush et al gore
oui enfin c'était pas tout à fait le
même cas de figure dans le cas de bouche
et de gore lé recomptage des voix en
floride avait été demandée car l'état
était enfin la victoire dans l'état
était contesté la cour suprême avait
déclaré en décembre je crois le 12
décembre 2000 la victoire de busch en
floride ce qui a fait basculer les
grands électeurs le nombre de grands
électeurs dans son dans son camp alors
que gore avait remporté le vote
populaire c'est un des paradoxes ldd
limite disons de leur système électoral
indirecte de suffrage universel indirect
qui fait que parfois le candidat qui
remporte le suffrage du grand nombre de
suffrages nationalement ne remporte pas
forcément un le l'élection la cour
suprême à ce moment là avait été saisi
c'est ce que veut faire la donald trump
au cas où on ne sortirait pas victorieux
est ce qu'on peut s'attendre à des
violences on sait que plusieurs villes
se sont barricadés on l'a dit au début
notre entretien c'est plus aujourd'hui
un référendum pour ou contre donald
trump et on sent que quand même les
états unis les américains voilà son sont
assez en colère contre la
la gestion de la crise sanitaire contre
la gestion du pays pendant ces quatre
ans par donald trump
oui tout à fait donc là si on est dans
le scénario en fait le pire qui pouvait
se dérouler c'est à dire le scénario
d'un d'une élection extrêmement serré ou
ils les résultats pourront être
contestées si la victoire avait été
clair pour un camp comme pour l'autre il
aurait été plus facile de se projeter
dans un avenir calme passage dans une
transition ou dans une prolongation du
pouvoir plus plus calme là si donald
trump commencent à revendiquer la
victoire avant que les résultats ne
soient connus partout biden l'a
d'ailleurs bien dit tout à l'heure
lorsqu'il s'est exprimé
vers 6h40 tout à l'heure il a exprimé le
fait qu'il attendrait le résultat les
résultats définitifs dans chacun des
états qui ne savourait pas vaincu et
donc on peut imaginer effectivement
détention peut-être des tensions
violentes des codes des possibilités de
friction et le chaos institutionnel est
tout à fait possible
washington ainsi que plusieurs villes se
barricadent depuis plusieurs jours de
peur de scènes de violence de violences
urbaines de pillages comme comme il a pu
avoir à l'est comme on a pu en voir
pendant le mouvement black line
donateurs le président trump également
appelé pendant son discours ferme disons
pendant le le premier débat présidentiel
contre bayonne il a appelé les preuves
boys qui sont des groupes d'extrême
droite à se tenir prêts à le défendre à
le soutenir
donc il n'a pas pas ces tensions encore
une fois en revendiquant la victoire
avant que n'ait été déclarée par la
presse ça se voit justement dans les
deux discours les deux sons de cloche
vous l'avez dit joe biden qui essayent
voilà de rassurer son électorat en lui
demandant d'être patient donald trump
qui au contraire affirment que voilà
malgré le décompte en cours
son camp a gagné cette élection
américaine
les ventes d'armes ont exposé
dernièrement aux états unis justement
vous pensez que c'est le facteur des
élections voilà ce ce côté violent qui
risque d'éclater dans les prochains
jours c'est un signe en effet que les
américains certains en tout cas sont
prêts à prendre les armes pour défendre
leur vision de l'amérique
donald trump est un grand défenseur du
port d'armes
c'est un général 1 quelque chose qui est
défendu plus tôt par les républicains
les démocrates sont beaucoup plus
modérée par rapport au deuxième
amendement et au port d'armes
là effectivement si on peut craindre des
tensions très violente d'ailleurs il ya
eu des épisodes assez récemment puisque
une tentative
de séquestration de
la gouverneure du michigan a eu lieu
avec des milices armées ya des milices
armées qui se sont qui se sont formés
qui se sont montrés qu'ils essaient
d'intimider aussi une certaine
frange de la population donc c'est vrai
que c'est assez inquiétant tout ça c'est
aussi dans les gènes disons historique
de l'amérique puisque on se rappelle que
ce sont par les armes que les etats unis
se sont se sont formés qu'ils ont
résisté à la grande bretagne lorsque ils
ont formé leur pays au moment de la
déclaration d'indépendance et c'est pour
cela d'ailleurs que le port d'armes est
inscrit dans la constitution pour
permettre aux américains s'ils le
veulent de contester la légitimité d'un
gouvernement qu'ils jugeraient
illégitime c'est pour cela d'ailleurs
que c'est c'est avec ces arguments là
que les que les américains se sont se
sont sont devenus un état indépendant
est une république et donc on peut
craindre effectivement une peut-être une
peut-être guerre civile a encore la
ville c'est vrai que le terme aux
guerres civiles est revenu à plusieurs
reprises
voilà une amérique qui est vraiment très
polarisée aujourd'hui que l'on va suivre
de très près bien évidemment ces
résultats qui continuent de de tomber
certains bureaux de vote sont dépouillés
pratiquement à 99% des bulletins
d'autres un peu moi en tout cas merci
beaucoup c'est le temple est d'avoir été
avec nous tout au long de ce journal